JAMIE DAVIDSON: Hi,
I'm Jamie Davidson.
I run the product
team at Looker.
And today I'm going to give you
a quick overview of what Looker
is today and where we're going.
Looker is an enterprise
BI tool and data platform.
We empower our customers to
make a smarter use of data.
On the top, you see the
diversity of use cases
the Looker platform can be
used to power from modern BI
and beyond.
And I'll talk about
that in a moment.
Looker's platform has a
couple of key differences
relative to the existing market.
Our customers come
with their data
aggregated from a wide
variety of sources
into a cloud data warehouse.
Looker has an
in-database architecture
that will leverage the
functionality, scalability,
and performance of technologies
like BigQuery, and enable
customers to drive real
time data value from.
We've got a semantic
modeling layer
on top of that in-database
architecture, where
an analyst can come and
codify their business metrics
and enable an organization to
have a single source of truth.
That modeling layer is
integrated with Git inversion
control and allows
for governance.
Looker is a cloud
native BI tool.
And that means
that everything you
can do inside the application
and more is accessible via API.
That architecture has a
couple of key benefits.
First, data governance is built
in from the ground up, too.
Because of the
modeling layer, because
of the integration with
Git, our security access
and authentication, you can
have confidence that the metrics
that your users or
your business is using,
or what you think
that they need,
and that the right
people have access.
That same semantic
modeling layer
also serves to empower
business users.
You don't have to know the
complicated definitions
for things like gross
margin or lifetime value
to be able to still make
directional decisions based
on that data.
Looker's a cloud
native application.
Every URL is shareable.
It means that you have
easy, repeatable analysis.
Because we have an
in-database architecture,
we are representing what's
live in the database today.
An in-database architecture
allows for operational use
of your data.
Because customers
are now replicating
their full transactional
information into a cloud data
warehouse, you can not just
look at the high level KPIs
and where they're trending.
You can actually see the
individual transactions
that are driving.
Over 50% of our customers now
are actually using the Looker
platform beyond API context.
To give you a
couple examples, we
see customers using us to
have embedded dashboards
in internal portals so that
their knowledge workers can use
data to make better decisions.
We see customers embedding
dashboards into SAS tools,
like Salesforce, so
that the salespeople
can go and have the relevant
information while they're
making their decisions.
We see customers integrating
us into existing products,
and even creating
completely new products
to give value to
their customers,
and at times, monetize data.
And then finally,
we see customers
going so far as to use Looker
effectively headlessly,
so not using any of our UI or
UX, integrating with our APIs
to provide governed data
into custom applications.
These applications don't
look or feel like anything
that classic BI would suggest.
It's beyond reporting
and self-serve analytics.
It's really operational.
So for example, maybe a supply
chain management application
where the historical inventory
levels and pricing is useful,
and Looker provides a
governed view of that
into that application.
So Looker is different.
We have a different
architecture, too.
And it gives some benefits.
We are fast on any size of data.
We're leveraging BigQuery,
and Snowflake, and Redshift
to be able to give
you real time access
to their powerful functionality.
The semantic model
means that there's
a single source of truth
for your organization, too.
And it gives the business
users trust in the data.
That model is integrated with
the development workflow, too.
It lets you have
changes over time
in a lifecycle of management
for those workflows.
And finally, Looker is a
Cloud native application, too,
which means we've
got APIs to integrate
with lots of operational tools.
We want to be where
the users are working.
That was a quick look
at what Looker is today.
I want to tell you
about where we're going.
We talked just recently about
the breadth of experiences
that we enable, or use
cases that we enable.
We think about the ability to
serve those use cases in three
real layers, too.
So the top layer is
data experiences.
This is where the business users
are consuming data and taking
action on it.
Below that, we've got our
application platform, too.
This is what enables our
customers to create those data
experiences.
And then finally, the
base, really, here
is Looker's foundation.
This is our
development lifecycle.
This is our ideas, our
query, our execution.
This is the core of the app.
So to start on data
experiences, I'm
going talk quickly about
the core unit of a report
for Looker as a dashboard.
I'll talk about how
we've completely
rebuilt that dashboard stack,
and how we're similarly
now re-imagining that the
core explore experience,
that self-serve analysis is
the expression of the model
as well.
We'll talk a little bit about
how we integrate into existing
business workflows, and
then finally close on
how we help with
content discovery.
So I mentioned that we've
been rebuilding our dashboard.
We've spent the
last year and a half
completely rebuilding
it from the ground up
with a bunch of
different goals in mind.
We want it to be a
more modern stack.
We want to be more performant.
We want it to be
more customizable.
We also want to enable
fundamentally new interactions
and experiences that haven't
ever been possible inside BI,
and that includes things
like cross-filtering
at petabyte scale.
Because we have an
in-database architecture,
and we can take advantage of
databases like the BigQuery,
we now have an interaction
mechanism, too,
that lets you get full
granularity of your data.
Ask as many questions as
you want of the content.
We rethought the
consumption of content.
We also had to think about the
creation of that content, too.
We want to give our analysts
a whole lot more control
over the presentation
of their data, too.
We want to make it easy
for them to create reports
that you can easily drive
insight from and ultimately
take action on.
And that includes things
like fundamental new modes
of consumption.
Here you can see
a new report type.
This is closer to a Google
Doc than it is to a dashboard.
It's still integrated with
the Looker governance.
our security model, too.
You can see it's
infused with data.
It's got a live look and
visualization of metrics, too.
But it's presented
in context, too.
Imagine you're an executive
consuming weekly PDF
report emailed to you, too.
The analyst needs
to construct it
in such a way where you can
easily derive insights from it,
too.
[INAUDIBLE]
So this can allow that.
We're also increasing
our customization
as possible inside
dashboards, too,
with new dashboard
extensions, where
you can take over a
tile of a dashboard,
too, with pre-built
extensions that
are present inside
our marketplace,
as well as custom extensions
that you build, too,
to allow you to create custom
experiences and workflows
to tailor to your data.
We're really excited about
bringing Looker more broadly
to as many people as possible.
That includes doing
work like localization.
We now support 23
different languages, too,
for our core
reporting use cases.
We are in the
process of bringing
all of that localization
to the full application.
Similarly, we're looking
at accessibility as well.
We want to make
it easy for Looker
to navigate for all users,
too, so that everyone
can derive value from it.
We're looking now
at exploration, too.
And Looker's explorer has always
been an incredibly powerful
feature.
It's the manifestation
of that semantic model.
It lets you ask lots of
questions of your data, too.
We want to make it even easier.
We want to make it so you
have smarter starting points,
so pre-built queries to start
the question and answering
process.
We want to make it so that you
can do on-the-fly calculations,
and not have to
go into the model
to create new metrics
or dimensions, too,
that are just transformations
on existing ones.
We also want to take advantage
of GCP's best-in-class AI
and ML functionality, too,
and integrate some of that
into the BI tool so
that you'd have things
like time series
forecasting to integrate it
into the explored experience.
We want to bring
data to wherever work
is being done at a high level.
We want to drive more value.
That requires things like
our learning functionality.
We've got analytical alerts that
use data to power workflows.
We want to make
them even smarter.
We want to use that same AI and
ML expertise that GCP has, too,
do things like outlier
detection, where analysts
can come in and say, this
metric is important to me.
Let me know if it changes,
and maybe tell me why.
We can do that.
We'll be bringing
that into [INAUDIBLE]..
We want to make it easy
to take action directly
from within the BI experience.
So this is building
on our action
help, which is
tightly integrated
with our semantic model.
It allows for interaction
and integration
with third-party services.
So in this case, you could
have complex analysis
inside the BI tool to find
over-performing campaigns, too,
and then take direct action
to change their budgets
or change activity inside
the Google Ads platform.
We recently released an
integration with Google Sheets.
We're really excited.
Customers have adopted
it incredibly quickly,
because they wanted
to take governed,
trusted data, too,
into a context
sometimes where
they want to have
some lightweight ad hoc analysis
to customize experience.
We're excited about
this integration.
We want to bring it forward.
We want to do a
bi-directional integration
where Google Sheets
can basically
pull Looker data
and Looker consent
data into Google Sheets.
We're also excited about
integrating with the broader G
Suite products.
We've got lots of customers
that create slideshows that
are weekly operational
reports, where they
go through a process of
downloading a bunch of images,
and reconstituting that
slideshow or deck every week.
We want to make it so
that you have live access
to governed data, in the
context where you're working,
too, to enable that data
storytelling within slides,
or similarly within Google Docs.
We've got a deep
integration with Slack,
where you can send
data from Looker
into Slack and request
data of Looker from Slack.
We want to make that interface
of requesting data even easier
in that communications
context, too,
extending to a natural
language interface
to that semantic model.
We're really excited about
a new native mobile app
experience we've got for IOS
and Android in beta today,
and we'll be GAing
over the course
of the second half of
this year, where you can
consume your data on the go.
We also want to expose that
natural language interface
in this context.
It's not enough to have your
content inside your instance,
though.
If you can't find it,
it's not useful, too.
And we're really
excited now that we're
part of Google,
the search company,
too, to really invest heavily
in that content discovery.
We're rebuilding our
search infrastructure
for a couple of goals--
better performance, better
relevance-- but also
with an eye to help with some
of the fundamental problems
that the BI always has.
If you don't have
a piece of content,
say you're searching for annual
recurring revenue, you don't
have a piece of content
that's relevant,
we can automatically
generate that content
to give you a live look at your
total ARR inside that search
context, too.
The data experiences
side, we are
focused on reporting
and self-serve analysis,
integrating with your workflow,
and driving more value
from your data.
I'm going to switch gears now
and talk about our application
platform.
This is where
customers and partners
build those data experiences.
And we're very focused
here on a couple of things.
We want to help accelerate
value for our customers.
We want to increase
both the customizability
and power that's possible
inside the embedded context,
and also extend the platform.
To accelerate value, we've
released a marketplace
that's in beta currently,
where you can easily
find, install, and manage
pre-built pieces of content.
So these can be applications.
These can be LookML blocks.
These can be data sets.
These can be custom
visualizations.
And they will dramatically
accelerate your ability
to actually explore.
One of those contexts and
one of those data sets,
too, is Google Marketing.
We've had a application and
a series of LookML blocks,
too, that are targeted on
marketing, [? in this case. ?]
We're really excited to
leverage the expertise in Google
to push this, really,
a whole lot further.
We want to help our
customers be able to gather
all of their marketing
data together to analyze
and find insights from
it, too, and ultimately
take action on that data,
too, within the BI experience.
For embedding, we think that
there's a spectrum, actually,
of need for customization.
And it sort of goes
from, on one side,
there's inside the
BI tool, and there's
customization that's possible
inside a dashboard experience,
or inside an embedded
dashboard experience
where you have
themes so that it can
feel like the application
it's embedded in.
We want to increase the
amount of customization that's
possible in that context.
Similarly, we've got our APIs on
the other end of the spectrum,
too.
We want to both increase the
customization as possible,
but also give you more
out of the box there, too.
So we want richer
APIs, better SDKs
for interfacing with
those APIs, too,
and then even high-level
JavaScript-based components,
too, so it's much easier to
be able to create [INAUDIBLE]
workflows to customize.
So as an example,
here is a dashboard
that's been themed so
that it can basically
fit into an application,
too, and feel native.
We very literally took our
new dashboard code base, too,
and packaged up the new
functionality and features,
too, in a JavaScript
component SDK
so that customers
don't have to recreate
filters or visualizations and
integrate them with our APIs.
They can, instead,
take our visualizations
and extend them,
and customize them
in any way that might fit
their specific workflow.
We're investing heavily
in our APIs and SDKs, too,
from documentation to more
robust interactions as well.
And we're also focused
on extending what's
possible inside the platform.
I'm really excited to talk
about the extension framework.
We've got a bunch of
partners and customers
that are excited about
the potential here.
The extension framework
is the ability
to host custom JavaScript
in a sandboxed environment
within your Looker instance,
too, and have direct access
to Looker's API so
that you can leverage
security and governance.
And it's a part of
the Looker platform.
There are lots of different
potential applications.
I'll give you a
couple of examples
to show what's possible.
We've released our
first extension--
I mean, our marketplace,
too, and our data dictionary.
This is closely integrated
with our data model APIs, too.
It can show analysts
and developers
the data that's present and
the definitions behind them
in a simple, easy place.
We've got a lot of
partners and customers
that are excited
about creating custom
ways to explore their data.
Going beyond the pivot table
metaphor of the Explore page,
there are contexts to where
a more tailored experience
actually makes sense.
So in this example,
the cohort tool,
it's a very
parameterized workflow,
where you select a measure, you
select an aggregation place,
you select the interval that
you want to measure cohorts on,
as opposed to needing
the full canvas
of [INAUDIBLE] pivot table.
Another example is actually
a hosted notebook experience,
where you can leverage
the power of Python,
integrated with the
Looker API, too,
and go beyond what a classic
Explorer experience would be.
Really excited about the
application platform.
We're focused on increasing
the customization
inside the embedded experience,
increasing the performance
there, too, and accelerating
value for our customers.
I'm going to switch
gears and talk
about the foundational
core of Looker.
Here, we think about things
like our software development
lifecycle and IDE for
the data developers.
We think about performance.
We think about
transformations that can
power that performance, too.
And how can we leverage
the data model?
Looker's always been
tightly integrated
with a development workflow.
And we want to continue
to push that forward.
We want to have a full quality
assurance process, too,
in a single instance that
allows for development, staging,
and verification of development
and production environments.
And we want that to be
inclusive of your LookML models,
of your content, and even your
transformations in database,
too.
It's in the service of
driving some performance.
And Looker's
in-database architecture
gives us the ability to
actually drive performance
in a layered approach.
We can take advantage of
best-in-class functionality
of data warehouses, too.
And they also use BI contexts
to help inform queries
and drive more
performance queries.
We've got a much
customers really excited
about aggregate awareness.
We released it a few months ago,
where you can create roll up
tables within Looker.
And Looker's platform
will have the intelligence
to be able to dynamically
optimize queries based
on the questions or the
query that's coming in.
So if you're going for a
granular piece of information,
we can go to the
full granular table.
If you're looking
for a summary, you
can go to the high
level [INAUDIBLE]..
And to power that
aggregate awareness,
too, we've been investing
heavily in our transformation,
so making them much more
robust and more durable.
We're focused on adding new
functionality, like the ability
to actually incrementally load
into your aggregate tables,
and integrating those
transformations [INAUDIBLE]..
We're taking a layered
approach to performance
and acceleration.
We want to take advantage of
the best-in-class functionality
like BigQuery's BI engine
inside the database.
It's an in-database cache,
specifically targeting
BI use cases.
Similarly, we also have
a new in-memory cache
as well inside the
look application layer
that eliminates the need to do
round-trips to the database,
too, when they're not necessary.
We think about administration
a little bit differently.
We think about it from an
analytics-first perspective.
We want to give you
as much information
about the usage of
your Looker platform
to help you drive
data-driven decisions.
And so you can use the
actual query performance
to help drive
performance optimization.
You can use the
actual user engagement
to help better
captivate your audience.
Looker's data model
is the key reason
why our BI tools differentiate.
It's that integration
with the data model,
and understanding of the
transformational logic
that's present inside.
We have a bunch of
customers now using
that transformational logic in
other workflows or use cases
outside of Looker.
So we've got a bunch
of customers now using
stable roll-up tables,
too, inside the database
to power machine
learning workflows,
where they've got governed
definitions of features
for their machine learning
training processes,
too, that are
governed by Looker,
but used in other contexts.
Similarly, we also want to help
further leverage the Looker
model, too, like we're doing
inside the Google Sheets
integration.
We want to basically
let analysts
use the right analytical tools,
too, on top of governed data.
We think we create more value
when you give governed trust
and access to that data, too,
regardless of the context
where it's being consumed.
Looker and GCP firmly
believes that customers
have the right to choose.
They have the right to choose
the right infrastructure
for the right problem.
We firmly support that, too.
We currently support hosting
Looker inside GCP, inside AWS,
and we're actively working
on supporting Azure.
We are also very
focused on security.
It's a large effort inside our
engineering and product teams.
We've already got our
[INAUDIBLE] type 2.
We've already got our ISO
27K, and our PCI [INAUDIBLE],,
as well.
We're actively working
on additional security
certifications, too.